how do we find the median of this set of
numbers we know that the median is the
middle or the central value but only
after we arrange the terms in ascending
order this is the ascending order of the
set 2 4 6 12 12 16 and 18 now to find
the median we just have to look for the
middle value this is the middle term it
has three terms on its left and 3 on its
right 12 is the median of this set of
numbers and the median as we can see is
the fourth term first second third and
the fourth what we should be interested
in is this number fall which term is the
median look at the set of numbers we
have seven terms here and four can be
written as 7 plus 1/2 it's 8 by 2 which
is 4
we can say that the median is the n plus
1 by 2's term here in a 7 which is why
we say that the fourth term is the
median will this work for any and every
set this formula works only when the
number of terms in the set is odd that
is only if n is odd what happens when n
is even look at this set it has 8 terms
to find the median we first arrange the
numbers in ascending order it will be 7
7 14 15 17 24 29 and 42 what will be the
median in this case as there are 8 terms
we cannot find one central value within
the set the median will be the average
of the two central terms 15 and 17 it
will be 15 plus 17 by 2 and that will be
32 by 2 which equals 16 16 is the median
of the set of values but how do we
generalize it
which term is the median look at 15 it
is the fourth term and n is 8 so 15 is
the N by 2 X term
what about 17 17 is the 5th term it is
actually the term after this 117 is the
N by 2 plus 1 X term so the median is
the average of the N by 2 eighth term
and the N by 2 plus 1 F term but this is
only when n is even
you